So I've come up to the
University of Leicester, and
I've brought with me a tube
here containing Caesium.
Caesium is found in the
far corner here.
And it is the most reactive
metal in the entire periodic table
Even more reactive
than Francium.
This is a radioactive element
and it decays.
But actually, Caesium is more
reactive than this.
It's the most reactive
thing we can find.
Now, why have I come
up to Leicester?
I brought this because I want to
see how it reacts with the
most reactive, non-metal in
the entire periodic table.
And that's the element
Fluorine.
And we don't think this has
ever been shown before, so
we're not entirely sure
how it's going to go.
So I'm gonna go and see.
Having decided that I wanted to
do this crazy reaction, I
needed to find just the right
person to handle the Fluorine.
And this is Professor Eric Hope
here from the University of Leicester
So, thank you very much for
helping me out with this.
-You're welcome.
And what was your first
reaction, by the way, when I
said I want to try Caesium
with Fluorine?
I thought you were totally
and utterly mad.
Uh huh.
That's probably most
people's reaction.
Now we've designed this
apparatus with
quite a lot of thought.
One of the problems here
is that we want to do this at the Ri
And transporting Fluorine is
a little bit tricky, is it?
Certainly.
It reacts vigorously, as we will
see, with virtually any
element in the periodic table.
Eric's come up with this
fantastic idea of just filling
the coils in the apparatus, this
plastic tubing that has
been sensitised to fluorine
so it's not going
to react with it.
Basically, what we have in here
is Fluorine, but at the
same pressures there is in the
atmosphere around it that
nothing's going to leak in,
nothing's going to leak out.
So even if there was a major
event, then the Fluorine would
not be released from
the apparatus.
To show the extreme reactivity
of Fluorine, we're going to set fire to something
We all know how hard it is to
start a barbecue using this stuff
This is charcoal, trying
to get it to burn with the oxygen from the air
I'd be easy, though, if the
atmosphere contained Fluorine.
Is this your one or
is this my one?
-No that was yours, I think.
OK, was it?
-No.
You see.
OK, should we see the
reaction then?
-Let's have a go.
This demonstrates the extreme
reactivity of Fluorine gas.
This was a tiny quantity of
Fluorine being played onto the
surface of the charcoal there.
And as soon as the two came into
contact, there was this
very violent reaction, generated
a lot of heat, as
you saw the flames there.
But the charcoal isn't
terribly reactive.
Caesium is much more reactive.
So I think we should try
this reaction now then.
This is my Caesium.
Have you seen Caesium before?
-No.
There's quite a lot of
it, isn't there?
Quite beautiful.
-Beautiful, yes.
And so dangerous.
So this is a combination between
the two most reactive
elements in the periodic
table.
We've got Fluorine, the most
reactive non-metal, and
Caesium, the most
reactive metal.
Let's push them through again.
-Yep.
Yeah, it looks good.
All right, we are
nearly ready.
I'll lower this.
-Yep, and I'll turn.
You look after your pipes.
Incredibly beautiful
reaction there
between Caesium and Fluorine.
This intense light.
And I don't think many people
have seen that before.